[Music]
welcome welcome to our session on dev
101 one platform for your function is
applications and containers maybe the
first question how many of you attended
the dev 108 session yesterday
introducing native and over again good
good
if you haven't that session did a good
really good overview of general drivers
for the project what some of the reason
for Google to open-source native as well
as introduced letter a lot of the
partners and open source frameworks that
are collaborating with us on that a
might be worth giving a watch all right
so let's start with maybe a oh by the
way there's a video of that session
available already today so dev 101 108
let's do quickly maybe start with a
little interest hi I'm Billy I guess
I've been at Google for about 11 years
be working in the cloud for about nine
or so I was one of the first engineers
on the kubernetes project the cloud
storage and a few other open source
project that's of light like helm I've
been involved service catalog and most
recently Kay native right
and my name is March Marnie I'm one of
the technical program managers
responsible for service at Google
all right so apparently I'm hearing
kubernetes is pretty popular nowadays
and great understatement I suppose it's
growing popularity has really driven
kind of to become the facto target for
many of the workloads and why not people
are benefiting from the abstraction of
the underlying infrastructure it
simplifies a lot of the the pains
related to that the broad support from
pretty much very every single one of
cloud service provider nowadays or also
assures a lot of portability for your
workloads and the rich ecosystem of
point solutions
filling the gaps around kubernetes means
that you can take your your solution and
really kind of adapted and and deploy it
so overall I know there is still room
for improvement I think we can still
make it a little better but overall the
operator experience the person who
managed
ladies it's pretty smooth but how about
the developer how about the developer
experience people who people who build
on top of kubernetes well we think that
that experience is not as great I think
there's still a lot of room to
improvement because developers on the
end of the day I really just want to
write code unfortunately today if you
look at the kind of the experience of
developer on kubernetes a lot of the
work in addition to writing code also
kind of mimics that the experience of
the operator there's a fair amount of
plumbing to do a fair amount of
networking fair amount of implementation
and so forth so I'm gonna introduce
again because apparently every session
has to introduce native so we've
introduced native again for those of you
who have not attended the previous
session just a quick highlight
kubernetes based building blocks for
servlets workloads so one of the key
kind of drivers of keen properties of
native is that it sets some key
primitives for building applications on
top of native it provides initially
built eventing and serving those are
very first efforts to kind of simplify
that experience and we're gonna go after
other areas for reason to it solves many
of the modern development patterns what
I mean by modern here is that if you are
bringing a database as a single node
database probably not the greatest place
to run this on top of native today but
if you're looking for a micro service to
build micro services stateless micro
service or 12 factor applications
native really solves a lot of good
problems or issues related to deploying
and type of kubernetes those type of
workloads it implements also native also
implements a lot of good learnings from
from Google including you know 10 plus
years on appengine kubernetes and East
EO itself from the open source community
as well as number of contributions and
and kind of feedback and inputs from our
partners so these are the companies like
Red Hat I am pivotal and sa P that have
worked with us before we even opened the
repo over the last six months or so
we really could not have been where we
are today without without them in
addition to that we also have started
collaborating very early with a number
of open source frameworks out there a
function as a service frameworks that
there are kind of building on top of
kubernetes and the signal that was
coming out of that that was really good
is that many of them already either
taking native as an ingredients into
their stack or Repat forming the entire
framework on top of native to simplify a
lot of the boring tasks that are related
to running your framework on top of
kubernetes alright so very quickly we if
you look at our documentation if you
look about any of the materials we
publish we often talk about the
different personas we talk about the
developer we talk about the operator I
think I want to take a very quick 30
seconds here to just capture some of the
differentiation the people who
contribute to natives who write code and
improve the native stack itself are the
are the contributors here they help the
project and improve it then people who
take that code and instantiate it create
a instance of that and run it there we
call them operators they can do that on
any certified kubernetes instance that
are offered as a service everything
we're going to show you today is going
to be on top of GAE but that's the
limitation should not be there for any
of the demos to reproduce it and then on
the end the people who are consuming
that service that has been instantiated
by the operator and using only the api's
are the developers and and really today
everything we're going to do is going to
focus over here
I think there frankly could be another
session about the operator and the
community of large - all right so Villa
why don't you give us a quick overview
of the objects and give us a maybe a
demo later thank you alright so again
thanks for coming so that was a lot of
great information on why we did some of
these things and and what we are
focusing on today and that really is the
developer as in why do you care right so
what we are going to be doing is maybe
switching us
stay green one okay so when we started
building this thing one of the things
that we wanted to make sure it's easy
for you to come in this platform and to
be able to feel very comfortable and
feel very at home with this so when you
go ahead and come into a new system you
shouldn't have to have a very huge
cognitive overload of understanding all
kinds of different things that you might
not care about right now so when you
come to Kay native the first day
experience should be extremely simple
you should be able to come in and you
should be able to say hey that's some
code over here I would like to run in it
so we want to make sure that experience
is really easy we also want to make sure
that the API surface is is familiar to
you if you have used cuber navies right
so if you come in to kubernetes and all
of a sudden you have to do something
that is not native and no pun intended
then it's very tricky for you to call
and say well wait a minute I want to do
this but when I use your system I have
to do that so let's go ahead and and
take a quick look and see and we switch
the demo machine and just see what does
it feel like when you come into this on
your or day one mispronouncing Kay
native the whole time so I think there
is over under going on on Twitter right
now so very quickly just to layout
because we're going to be doing a lot of
demos you're going to see a lot of
console I is going to be three panels
throughout the entire session today
we're gonna on a very top we're gonna
see the current workloads which we don't
have any right now
but we're gonna spin up some in a minute
on that bottom left we're gonna just
quickly see the we're gonna use scale
which is open source project to view and
stream logs from kubernetes we're gonna
see the logs there in a different
namespace and over here we're gonna be
running a bunch of commands all right so
everything when I show you again is some
type of G key on top of native that's
been instantiated using the
documentation that's in it in the
repository so if you wanted to reproduce
any of what we show where we show you
today you could do that right away
alright so let's let's apply that image
that manifest and again Villa was
talking about K native being idiomatic
or
to ative if you've worked on kubernetes
before native wants to use your
experience with kubernetes itself and
leverage that to kind of unable you to
be a better developer on top of
kubernetes so we quickly see native spun
up a take a look at maybe that manifests
itself we've used the very simple as
simple as physically possible
manifesting here deploying a pre-built
container you've seen that yesterday
maybe in a demo you've seen this many
times
what native done here for you however is
plumbed up all the other things
connected logging deploy your routing
and everything like that so let's maybe
navigate quickly to here let's try to
invoke it hello GCP you've got to have
this awesome
20:18 mate ooh 20:19 good almost as we
wanted to show this way
so let's come back here and switch that
to 18 just to show you how quickly and
easy is to deploy it again I didn't have
to do any new work just apply the exact
same exact same file way for weight for
native to do its magic we're going to
talk about exactly what's going on
behind the scene in a minute wait for
the three of three switch over here okay
let's open you to simple I wonder if my
chrome is caching some things here there
it is all right can we switch back to
slides please all right so that's great
it's great to come in there system where
you're gonna have a really nice easy way
to get started right many of these so
far you haven't shown you really
anything all that special right there's
many tools that you can already do this
with today you can go ahead and have
template solutions you can download
things that wire things for you already
so that part is not really all that
exciting but one of the things that we
also wanted to make sure that we work
very hard on on designing the system is
to make sure that the define very clear
set of principled objects so you can
reason about the object model that we
are built so every object that you see
in the system you should be able to go
and look at and saying like I know
exactly what that does if I need to do X
I know what I need to look at
so in kubernetes today I like to think
of it as the
language level for the cloud native
programming so there's a lot of very
good building blocks there and if you
put them all together just the right way
it's gonna be awesome but what we are
trying to do here is build you maybe
something like ellipse e standard Lib
something like that higher level
primitives that not everybody has to
build those like in the battle place
everybody was building their own
libraries okay so we started off with a
very simple object right it took two
things it says here's my code run it and
here's some conflict with it and you can
come in and very easy to go ahead and
iterate on that push some new code
everything works fantastically almost
fantastically so underneath what what we
did is we took that service object and
we created a configuration out of that
okay
so configuration is another great
practice that is is taking your software
the code and the configuration and
putting them together so that it's a
it's a self-contained unit right so you
know this is a pretty standard practice
from 12 factor and putting together all
your stuff in one place and making sure
that it doesn't get out of sync okay
whenever you make modifications the
configuration object or when you create
one underneath K native will go in and
create a revision out of that so you
interact with the configuration object
and underneath if K native we'll go in
and make a revision object for you and
whenever you make a modification to a
configuration K native will stamp out a
new version of revision so at the end of
the day for every modification that you
have made you will have a new version of
it so you have a linear history of all
the changes that have been applied to
your code so that's pretty nice right
what do I do with that well you probably
look away and put some traffic into that
and that's where we have our out object
right so we are now go ahead and being
able to come in and saying okay great I
have some software over there that I
built and I can easily go and make
modifications to it with the route
object you can come in and be very
specific about how traffic flows into
those objects ok so again let's just
pause there just for a second so the
roles and responsibilities are very
clear here so if you look at the top of
the box service that is very dev AAPIs
right
basically pushing your code in whenever
you make a change it goes out I started
serving traffic and as you grow you can
start seeing we are going down to stack
a little bit where you can say hmm maybe
I have a clear operate of role where the
operator is responsible for shuffling my
traffic and the developer can go ahead
and worry about pushing code so let's go
and see what that looks like so again
great on day one it was good to be in
that land of just pushin code see it go
live exciting great times then you start
taking some customers and you might
wanna change your practice a little bit
so let's see how native grows with you
okay so here's what we're gonna do now
here we're just gonna go through a
couple of slides together here just so
we can set the stage on what it is that
we are gonna do and then mark is gonna
demo it after then but let's go ahead
and say so so this is roughly what we
had after we deployed the very first
version of the software right so we have
a route that is shuffling a hundred
percent of the traffic to the
configuration that only has one revision
right that's all great so we are only
specifying that one hundred percent
traffic goes there now let's push some
new code okay but we don't want to shift
any traffic to it because we brought
them gonna validate that that new
version is so hopefully you have some
unit tests don't look at me Scott but
then you might have some integration
tests as well and then you might want to
go ahead and test your entire stack
against the new version without
affecting any of the possible production
traffic that you have going on okay
so what we do here is we go in decay
native and we say hey route what I would
like to do is I actually would like to
create two targets I'm gonna go and
create one that is targeting my old one
and I'm gonna go and create a new one
for my second one the blue green one but
I'm not gonna give it any traffic yet oh
and also please give it a name so I can
talk about it right because that name is
not really friendly so give me two give
it a fancy name so push the new software
no changes to your traffic let's so then
typically you would maybe start rolling
out your traffic a little bit you might
say okay well typically maybe two
percent experiment or 50 percent or
whatever else it is but mark likes to
live on the edge so he's just gonna go
straight to 50 I
he's silly but you know whatever so now
we are basically gonna call and said
great let's go into 50/50 traffic split
just so we can see how things work
because in a demo it would be more wonky
to run at 2% and then in the end once we
validate everything that's when we can
go and shift all of our production
traffic to the new version happy making
money and then we can turn off the old
version but we'll still leave it around
in case we need through a quick little
rollback we can do that so let's call
that version 1 so let's see what that
looks like on the demo machine please
alright so what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna kind of go through the same
process of blue green there we go
same process first of all we're going to
deploy our basic basic application we've
we've showed you how to do this before
so I'm not going to talk too much about
that just to create the initial state
what would happen when you deploy your
stock so this is blue green and we're
gonna talk about stage 1 so let's deploy
that wait for kinetic to create the
instance of that all the necessary
resources you see some activity going on
here and magic happens there we go so
alright so we have our instance stood up
its run the day one the joy of deploying
software is there everything is great
but then you say well I would like my
thing to be you know something better or
fix them some bag so let's go over here
and take a look at the stage two very
much the same deployment another
revision just like we've done before
another configuration but in addition to
this we're also going to create that
initial routes tab that Villa was
talking about so how do % to this old
version 0% to the new version of course
deploying application that doesn't have
way to access to would not be fun so we
give it a name route so we can give it a
get get to it so let's deploy the stage
to in here
again we're going to wait for for this
to magically happen
all right I can start switching over
here and now what I can do is I can
continue refreshing this you will see
the traffic continues going to the
original version but the beauty of this
is that now we have this v2 in here that
I can also peek at even though hundred
percent of the traffic is not going none
of the traffic is not going over there
all right so now we've done with
revisions we've basically deployed two
versions of the application from now
onwards all we're gonna do is we're just
going to deal with that route object in
here by the way is this big enough
everybody can see over there
so in here we're gonna do this very
aggressive switching for the purposes of
demo which is gonna go 50/50 because I
don't want to hit the command are too
many times so let's apply this oops
stage 3
actually it's wait for a second here
it's all routes so there is nothing
magical here so going to back to the
original traffic 50/50 is happening no
it's not science so it's you know
round-robin of some sorts and then now
that we are successful that that stage
of where we fixed everything and we want
to deploy we shifting or setting the
traffic to the original version to 0 we
migrating everything to the new version
oh and by the way just to kind of have a
historical reference to get to the
previous version we're gonna name a new
route they will allow us to go to v1
again no magic in here let's finish this
switch over here let's just wait for
this for a second all right
I still struggler in there now
I'm pretty sure my crumbs caching
something there we go 100% of the
traffic and we still can as you have
seen with v1 with v2 before we can still
reach to the old version if we want it
to explicitly all right can you switch
back to slides all right so a couple of
things that are interesting about that
demo that I'd really wanted to point out
which is as we started with the original
one that was really easy to come in and
get started and it was more like again
with the DevOps model will just push
code everything goes through by
introducing configuration and route up
objects now what you can do is you can
go ahead and start defining not only
roles within your organization but also
with this objects by introducing things
like our back rules so you can say okay
devs you can push code all day you want
but none of it is gonna make it into
production because I will be in control
of the route object which seems nice so
okay so that was great so we talked
about how to get the code out there in
the cloud everything is hunky-dory happy
but K&A did what have you done for me
lately right so let's go ahead and talk
a little bit about some of the other
aspects of server lists that are
typically things that you want to have
out of the system right so the first one
that we're gonna talk is is the you know
manually work you're half way to work
home and then you realize oh my goodness
did I leave the stove on right so this
is the equivalent of you know did I just
spin up a whole massive test stack that
it's gonna be running there the whole
weekend burning cash money flying out
right so Kay native can you take care of
that for me right so one part of the
service is you don't think about server
lists so why would you care about it if
you left the stove on Kay native should
be able to say you know what it's not in
use let me go and put it away okay
that's great
the other way that it handles is you
know there's this there's this very
Unversed the asari Unversity bursty
under dispersed the traffic right
traffic pattern is not always like this
right so your software makes up into the
reddit or hacker news or whatever the
greatest new thing is that you find this
software right so you're gonna get some
new users and you're gonna get bursty
traffic and everything else you don't
want to have to worry about how many
servers
running and-and-and did I bring up
enough cards and did I do this and that
and everything else K native should just
handle that for you as well right and
also it's easy to go and take away
resources when they are not in use it's
not so easy to go and bring them up and
they actually are needed so going from
one to zero is actually pretty
straightforward you just delete things
but it's more tricky to go and bring
them back up and then when they are
actually needed to go and service
requests when the traffic actually comes
back up so let's go ahead and see how
cane ativ handles this for us kind of
behind the scenes let me switch the demo
machine please the demo please thank you
alright so to do this we're gonna use
the very first application we deployed
during the first demo as you can see
however that the demo is not here
because thankfully I was afraid that
some of you gonna go to the browser and
start hitting it nobody went there and
therefore there was no traffic to it so
let's let's see what we're gonna what
happen if I start accessing this again
and either behind the scene start while
holding the traffic in and kind of
waiting for the resource the necessary
pod to be spun up brought it in and
there is our demonstration so this was
the cold start experience the famous
cold start that everybody talks about in
still very complex situation but a
native does the first attempt at kind of
solving that problem now I'm not gonna
go here with a browser and start hitting
at million times we're gonna go and use
a synthetic load - cheater yeah City
synthetic load - spin up about 20
different threads with 10,000 requests
for each one of those and switch over
here now native is gonna go and start
provisioning the necessary parts and
everything
watching command-line and watching
kubernetes provision parts as exciting
as watching paint dry I guess so let's
switch over to instance of our graph
Anna here that comes with native
pre-configured it comes with number of
different dashboards that the native
team Canada team has provisioned nicely
for us here
I'm gonna use two ones first of all
we're gonna take a look at take a look
at the traffic let's maybe go a little
to future here you will see three lines
I'm colorblind so I'm gonna tell you
what they told me what the colors look
like but we will see a the Green Line
which is the actual number of thoughts
we will see the desire number of what's
what native thinks you should have in
order to solve that traffic and the the
number of requested and you will see
that over us switch over here very
quickly show you the number of pods that
can I have spawn here for you there we
go there's some activity going on I
would say and refreshing we see that
this kind of what do you want what you
get and go on addition to that you can
also use a requester dashboard in here
hopefully you choose the right
application and refresh this well we're
not seeing any traffic in here well
there was the first Democrat I think we
should see the number of requests coming
in for that request I'm used using
simple all it might be something with
our mice my time in here alright
hopefully the other one was better
there we go already broke a demo now the
other thing is gonna go on if as soon as
the demo finishes which is which is done
you will see the native start
decommissioning the research the
necessary the no longer necessary pod so
we'll go in and start there we go I was
hoping for that to happen just like Ryan
yesterday I got just as lucky as he did
yesterday terminating the departs us as
the request starts coming in can we can
we change back to slides sorry we warned
you we're gonna be a lot of switching
there so that was pretty nice and there
was a couple of things that I'm of
somebody caught but so you could see how
the blue green tea deployments were
going away as well so those things are
all configurable for you so you can
decide what is the sleep off what is the
how long things
around before they are considered
obsolete well not obsolete but before we
can put them to bed for a better so
that's great so now we have sort of kind
of shown you how you can go and get your
software on the cloud and manage it and
things like that and we've sort of kind
of shown you how okay native comes in
and takes away some of the things that
you really don't care about in the
server let's land also what can they do
does for you is handling going from
source to code right so if you caught
all the examples we showed you so far
we're just taking a pointer to a
container right so again I said
developer I typically don't care about
then I just want to write the software
and I want to say run the software not
the container difference there's just
one my code so so we also have a
building repo that allows you to come in
and say okay my code is over there in
the gate or cloud storage or something
like that and you can come in and saying
please take that code just run it I
don't care about the bill do it so why
do you as a developer care right well
again once you go and get up your laptop
you get all the Machine all the tools
installed and everything else and the
project grows a little bit then you get
your friend working on it too and they
have a different laptop right and then
you start getting all those fun cross
compiling problems in the cross image
and nothing works anymore right so now
you can go and have an easy way to go
ahead and say you know what let's do the
built one way just once that seems
better
right um there's also no need for dr
locally right so that's nice i less
things i need to do on my machine less
things I need to upgrade less things I
need to keep running great perfect
right also there's performance
improvements out of this one because
when I'm running in the cloud I can take
advantage of the cloud caching so
typically the machines in the cloud have
much bigger pipes right so they can suck
right in and out faster right I can also
take advantage of caching behavior of
things like image layers right so if
you're building something chances are
somebody else is building at least lower
middle level parts of it and your code
goes on the top of their brain and then
the nice thing is that because it all
happens in the cloud now you can go and
start start creating things like audit
logs you can go and add additional
things into this tool chain that allows
you to go ahead and say hmm who did what
when and what right
and again this is something that is
loosely coupled so one of the things we
don't want to do is we don't want to
come in and saying in order to use K
native you must do things this way every
single time right so in the first
examples we showed you bring your own
own tool chain right so many of you
might already have a CI CD pipeline
running great everybody's happy
but this allows you to also go and say
you know what I don't really necessarily
need that let's just go ahead and use
this one or if you're coming in from the
other line where you are running into
github and building at the local machine
it allows you to move into the land
where you're coming in and saying like
you know what just handle it for me and
then maybe out of that you graduate
again to some CI CD pipeline or whatever
else and that's all fine and dandy but
again these are the kinds of things that
can ativ does for you automatically
giving you that server list thing server
is kind of what I'm gonna call it
promise but let's call it problems it's
just like you know going from source the
running code that's great there it is
and also the hey I don't worry about the
infrastructure right so so far we
haven't done anything here dealing with
machines or or lower oil details except
when we actually go look and make sure
that something is actually happening
right there boring demo it for me to do
that so we just kind of show those to
you but you don't have to worry about
that so okay
demo yes so let's switch the demo and
see what this looks like okay thank you
so what we're gonna do here we're gonna
take the the traditional get up
operation so we're gonna take github
repository or git repository hosted on
github we're gonna in this case we're
gonna follow a very simple application
that probably is as simple as one could
create a web server with and go but I'm
sure there's some room to improve it and
it has a docker file in here that
specify what I would like to build this
obviously this would apply for different
which is in different kind of formats
there so what are we gonna do here is
let's fire this job so we can talk about
it source alright so while this is
Canadian is spinning up the resources
let take a look at the manifest that was
used in this particular case again we're
building from github repo cañedo
supports both
public repositories as well as secrets
for for private repos so you don't have
to be dependent on exposing the entire
thing to the world and we're gonna have
a couple components in here first of all
is the the configuration component of
the build process which will include the
the sorts the source bit which will
indicate the source of the source of the
source I've seen the repository from
which we're going to pull as well as the
branch we want to pull from so it
supports multiple branches in addition
to this we're going to specify a
particular template can ativ supports
number of different templates we're
going to use in this case a conical
which is an open source project that
also already public to create an image
that will be pushed when done to a image
repository can connect also provides
certain kind of shortcuts so we're gonna
define a variable in here called image
that will hold this URL so in a rest of
the configuration we can just use that
variable the beauty of this is that when
we come in here when we start talking
about the actual target of the
deployment
we're gonna specify we want to target
deployed this as an application we want
to use the URL of the image once was
published to the image repository and
we're also going to define the other
environment variables that we've talked
about before the same way you would have
done for any other of the application so
let's take a look at where we are look
like image is still being built what's
what Canadia does is has a multi-phase
process involved in here so first of all
pulls all the necessary resources it
does certain months of configuration in
it then once the image is built
publishes the image then turns around
and uses the image just like it did if
you were building deploying application
from a published image in this case
we're seeing a 2 of 3 almost there
there we go so let's take a look at this
what is it
source image there we go
all right me switch back to the slides
please okay so the nice thing about one
additional thing I wanted to point out
here is that another reason why you
might wanna care about this is this is
totally pluggable so that so that you
can go ahead and have different kinds of
pipelines here so for example some
people have built things like dotnet
pipelines so you can go and build things
like that there there's built back
support and so forth so that that's also
very nice and customizable so it's not
only just docker thingies that we build
all right so great so so far again we've
talked a little bit about some aspects
of serverless but sometimes it seems
like they're you there we go am i there
yeah okay great I am here yes okay so so
it seems that over the last few years it
seems like what has come to be the norm
for serverless serverless equals equals
equals functions right that's always
right
well the K native there's there's bigger
thing that we are worrying about which
is serverless is much much bigger than
functions right so so we've been doing
serverless for a long time at that
vengeance so so we are kind of like
trying to put the two things together
however it does what be the one nice
thing about a server is the programming
model that typically resonates with most
developers is the eventing driven one
right so I have written some software
and now that's when I hit it with the
browser that is still event-driven when
I'm coming in and saying could you do
something for me
right but what we have done with the K
native is really given the first-class
principle objects for describing where
those events are coming from well so on
the bottom right there we have the event
consumers right so those are the things
that we have been deploying all day long
so far right so there's nothing
different about those things yeah just
pushing code rolling it forward doing
our testing and everything else so those
are the event consumers okay on the top
right we have the event sources right so
some something is producing events for
me right so this might be for example
github so github has a very rich
eventing source kubernetes cluster
itself is very rich anything that
happens in the cluster is it chances are
it's pushing out events for each one of
the event sources there's typically more
than one event type so the kind of event
it supports so for example the github
you have a pull request so if somebody
comes in and says hey here's a pull
request or if I make a commit those two
events are very different in their
context right and so there is there's
one-to-many relationship in Kay native
or event sources and event types right
and so what is left then is okay
I have those event types and sources and
I have my code here how do I wire them
together and for that there is an object
called a flow so with the flow you go
ahead and say mr. Kay native go over
there take those events from there and
wire them over to here right so let's go
and see what this looks like in practice
if we were to go ahead and and and to
see how how seamless it is to go ahead
and go from the application during
programming or just the you know pure
container model to the function in
programming using the same tool sets can
we switch the demo machine please almost
done couple more switches right so to
illustrate this what we're gonna do is
we're actually gonna wire the Canadia
into an event stream that's coming from
IOT devices google has a product called
IOT core core that provides the easy way
like a gateway for registering devices
and securely managing them with with
keys so what we've done here is we've
created one of those gateways
no code required is simply a gooey
operation the define define two
different types of protocols we're going
to be receiving on mqtt and HTTP define
our mocked-up IOT device because i
couldn't get one of those from our team
over there and it's called net 18 and
what sorry next 18 and we're also gonna
by default what coyote core does it
creates a like a sync for all those
events so in this case we're gonna have
two topics on pops up pops up is the
message broker in Google cloud that one
is for IOT data so that data itself the
other one is a metadata about the
devices that connect so you can event
things like my device has connected or
disconnected or certain threshold so
this is our source of events what are we
going to do here we're going to go in
and switch quickly and take a look at
the actual code itself now event flow
there we go
let's take a look at first the the code
that we use to publish it we've all
we've done here yeah we have some Go Go
things like defining the types but
bottom line is we've done one function
that handles the events they're gonna be
passed to me the cool thing about it is
that in this entire code there is no
references to pops up or any proprietary
google code you wrote idiomatic go
language the receives events this works
for node this works for any other
language you can support within around
time on native and when you do this
again we're not gonna do any fancy
things so we're basically just going to
print this entire thing to 2 command
line and see what's going to happen so
let's take a look at now the flow the
configuration portion of the entire
thing similarly to all the other way
we've configured our applications we're
gonna have a principal object as defined
by native the flow object that defines
the the name and all the other
parameters and it has two components one
is the trigger as in what we want to
connect to fro the source of events it
includes the name of the project as well
as the the topic as well as the
connection that this is the target for
where the events should be processed for
nothing new in here we've deploying a
simple function which is going to be
representing the route so let's go and
apply this flow
there we go we should see some
additional resources being created I
think
oh that's great that's just great
there we go
what native is doing now is going
through the operation of provisioning
dis roses no again I let's let's fire
the switch over here and generate some
data so we're gonna go and generate em
generate MQTT data is going to be super
simple it's simple object that
represents a source of the event the
unique identifier for each one of those
events some time stamp and a random
number between 1 and 10 this is as
sophisticated as it's gonna get today
I'm afraid
and then let's switch over here and what
we will see that using that
configuration we were able to let's see
let's do this let's take that IOT and
make decrease the noise level in here
little oh it's hoping it's helpful when
you spelled correctly what we see is the
output of those I haven't written any
specific code other than a calf unction
that handles events all the plumbing of
that into that that code into the route
was handled for me you'd still get you
still benefiting from all the other
principle properties of Native which is
the outer scaling which is the up and
down scaling and provisioning and all
that and these retract the slides please
great so bill the next slides for a
second great ok so just to make it more
concrete or we just saw right well as we
basically have to go function on the
bottom that Mark Braud but again we have
deployed that bit previously because one
of the concepts that wanted to
demonstrate is the notion of late
binding right so you wanna go and define
your function you wanna run the function
you want to go ahead and roll that
forward independent of how it is wired
to something else right so the function
is happily running notice it was
sleeping there right it was getting no
traffic and then he came up when we
started getting done and the pub/sub
eventsource and the topic where where
are events or cinnamon types in this
particular instance those are
user-defined also so you can come in if
you have some some existing systems that
you want to go and wire in there's a way
to come in there and extend the system
by providing glue logic to say okay this
is how you go ahead and configure things
and at the top except subscription that
mark showed for the flow was precisely
that it says there's the GCP pub/sub i
wanna go and get events from this topic
and I want them to wired into this go
function so that was pretty simple again
it was very very nice wait what what we
didn't show you there is that if you
that the nice thing is there's a clear
life cycle here so once you come in and
you delete that flow object it's gonna
go away and clean up so for example
pub/sub resources are are deleted and
again it decouples the event production
from the consumer which is a very nice
property okay now underneath again it is
there's a lot of complexity that we
don't get a chance to so show here but
there is additional resources that
typically are facing the operator
persona here so things like channels and
busses so that the traffic is shuffling
through there and so forth but but again
because we are focusing on what the
developer sees this is the developer
experience right here we are really
piggybacking off of CN CF cloud event
support so a lot of our friends at
Google and and colleagues over a
companies have been working on
standardizing the cloud events trying to
make sure that in the in the near future
that their standardization on what flows
on the on the wire there how do you
consume events and things like that so
so we are using that and and if you
looked at the code we had go types and
that's because well that code was
written a little while ago by now there
is cloud event support there too so yeah
but anyways so that's our eventing story
so we started this whole talk about
saying yeah you should come take a look
at K native because it helps you as the
developer so how did we do mark alright
so let's go back to this original is a
game developers just want to write the
code they want to do anything else we've
showed you certain demos that kind of
Illustrated the capabilities that native
enables the developers to not have to
worry about building docker images so
frankly you have you can be a developer
on native and not have any docker
components installed locally any dock
any image builds tools whatsoever none
of the pushing to registry either
deploy services we don't have to worry
about it we simply push the code
exposing this to the routes the routes
were creating for us automatically
the logging and monitoring was enabled
although looks like one of those new
monitoring capabilities was broken today
and we showed you also scaling so
scaling from 0 to 1 1 to 0 and 1 to N in
whatever order you want to go there so
lots of room to improve still but many
of the boring them the plumbing related
activities the developer has to do every
day hundreds of times if they're if
they're really developing is handled for
you by native automatic K native
automatically native is also extendable
now any software that anybody has ever
written implements opinions opinions of
that developer the candidate is no
different it provides implements the
opinions that we have based on the years
of learning from developing software at
Google at scale at the scale that Google
operates in clean implements opinions of
the partners and contributors to the
project but from the very beginning was
very important for us that these
opinions are are not held very very
tightly that we can change those as the
use cases come up
surplus is still very beginning stages
frankly at very very beginning stages
and things will evolve so we want to
make sure that this appearance can be
replaced when the use case you're
working on is not being served by
capabilities at native so a lot of that
is built is baked right into the API
that means event sources and types I
think if you go to our a github
repository today you will see examples
for pops up you will see github you will
see a couple other ones but it's not a
large portfolio of events we
gonna get better there it includes a
support for a number of different build
packs the pivotal team has put for
example provided a build pack for
c-sharp that we have not developed so
you can extend us and configure this
post installation on native it includes
a lot of network configuration so for
example for the demonstration today we
are using GCT gateway we're using a SSL
configuration for that was coming there
was a enable to us by native IP
configuration for static IP number of
different variables they're logging and
targeting now native Canada snot
obfuscates kubernetes underneath is
still kubernetes and you have still
access to it in fact i was using the
very same tool you're using to Nate to
manage kubernetes itself so if you feel
like it you could come in and change
some of the implementations that we've
done including the auto scaling strategy
I shows you auto scaling based on number
of requests you could base this on
latency - a connection to the database
or something like that I don't recommend
doing on the first day playing with
native but you could function seen
Walker's the community-at-large is
working on best way of implementing this
a forgo or Python or no js' amid the
different message buses that you can
implement there's a lot of different
customization options all right we have
three minutes to go and we do want to
leave some time for questions so I this
there's a couple links in here first of
all everything we've shown you today is
reproducible if you go to our documents
repository in King inkay native org you
can get there start from there and it
will navigate you to everywhere else you
could also if you don't want to play the
role over operator which we for the
purposes of demo I was playing you we
have a sign on for early access to serve
let's add on on gke
which will do all of that for you with a
single command give me K native boom
done or give me a service stack which
will which is kind of using the
components that we release later as open
source 4k native we also have a pretty
vibrant community already so if you
looked at it and go you know what this
sounds interesting I would love to
contribute or these guys don't know what
they're doing let me tell you let me
show you how it's really done
I come in here the community
inside of our repositories a good place
to start talks about the code of conduct
because about the kind of how get you
started and even highlight set of best
to start with issues that are already
out there and trust me there's a there's
a bunch of this there and as any hip
project nowadays we have a slack channel
that's open not sure that exact URL
works right now but if you go to the
github repo if you follow the
instructions there it will go there self
registration in slack is not smooth
Villa and I would love to hear your
feedback we would love to hear your
comments after a session or right now
yeah please please please notice one
favor and go to your handy-dandy mobile
devices or however you fill out the form
that says how we did it's very important
to us because if we get no information
then we can't improve so please take a
time it should be very very quick thank
you thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you